and their private episode is there
something else you wanted to tell me
even oh yeah no the thing has happened
even
how could you I studied air blaming you
should never have taken your eyes off
him wasn't it enough losing tail or no
you're right I did doing that
oh yeah after the Karthi no I'm going on
there at least it won't get infected
Thanks
you want anything Alec I witness our
little Joseph round yet did your
limousine that was the last time anybody
ever saw it did you know my father is
yes he only has to lift one finger you
won't wake up tomorrow morning you're
the one that should be afraid mr. Shelby
ah come out mr. origami Keller how how
to hit anyway ah this time it looks like
we got our origami killer next trial
next trial ye yes here we go
my favorite - why is not my controller
working there we go hey isn't that
doot-doot-doot okay I got him on what
the lesser I remember that are you
prepared to make a sacrifice to save
your son 971 marble straight it's pretty
good what I didn't do it I swear I
didn't do oh yeah I've got nothing to do
with that business I never killed no
naughty then why did you run away when
they came to question yeah exactly I
already told you I forgot to report to
my parole officer I didn't want to go
back to prison why are you going back to
our cops I just bolted I wasn't thinking
straight
we checked out his statement he has an
alibi for at least three the murders
[ __ ] that bastard was a perfect yeah
what's up [ __ ] ten [ __ ]
don't worry Diaz P we got this ash
Ketcham okay watch
Sean Martha's mother's here ah
she'd like to speak with you what has
happened I don't remember this what is
this
it was a few months back the middle of
the night it was pouring down Ethan came
home completely drenched at about 3:00 I
asked him where he'd been he he spoke
about drowning the rain um he didn't
make it
don't you die don't you [ __ ] die
you've done enough woman something in
his eyes you've done enough
has it it wasn't really him there may be
no connection but the next day there was
that announcement about another victim
of the origami killer [ __ ] find my son
I'm begging you
I kill her I'm police lieutenant Carter
Blake
this is agent Norman Jayden of the FBI
according to our information Ethan Mars
is one of us we'd like to ask you a few
questions about them I'm sorry I can't
tell anything
I beg your pardon mind bones by an oath
of secrecy yes under no circumstances
may I discuss my patients my job is to
find Shaun Mars alive and I don't give a
damn about any [ __ ] oath well we
should risk reason win it's your duty to
inform the police
if you suspect one of your patients
doctor I'm sorry I can't help you and
now I must ask you to leave you need to
cooperate you can do it for your own
sake I gotta take a [ __ ] really bad I
went back in um are you threatening yes
I'm just giving you some free advice doc
I really should get that agent all right
convince the shrink I know you don't
want to protect a murderer if you know
anything you must tell us doctor I'm
going to call the police and make a
complaint about your behavior comes like
about you huh behave doctor you are
really pushing my fight the only thing
I'm interested in save it at kid's life
so you're gonna be down touching Brown
Oh what I want to know what I'm really
gonna lose my temper sir a child's
life's at stake you may know something
like a lot are they need to help DSP you
have no right
what holy [ __ ] I'm a bad cop what you
gonna do what you gonna do huh can I
stop him I can't do anything
Hey
stop that'd be crazy
come on Doc there's an easy way in a
hard way
your [ __ ] shorts the hard way all
right you have no right
you have no right to hit him I'm saving
a kid's life for Christ's sake if you
don't like it leave
well I don't like it so I will stop your
DSP had enough I'm God I Rams you
[ __ ]
oh that's right we're gonna fight now
what's up with you knowing where you
getting cold feet you don't like to get
your hands dirty huh I thought you
wanted to save that kid
I want to save Shaun Mars just that's
right I do but that doesn't give me the
freedom to do what the hell I like so
you're gonna stop this [ __ ] right now
that's right
I'll get you for this job come on don't
worry don't be like that well not forget
what you were hearing an innocent man
logical problem since his first son died
feels responsible for his death
sort of morbid neurosis that's so
difficult to say he is haunted by
visions of drowning bodies a few weeks
ago after one of our usual sessions I
found this on the floor
it must have flown out of his pocket
ether Nesta killer
oh my god huh
what do we what it wanted one inhale
I guess it makes sense if you think
about it good cop
hell yeah but I got I got a cop am I
gonna come on I want you to cite every
available man to finding Ethan bars I
want a man outside his place day and
there's not going to be order by all
agencies to start looking for I want you
to keep an eye on the train stations the
airports the bus terminals I want every
cop in the city on his ass so if he
moves we know about it yes Ethan Mars is
the origin oh my spoilers oh my god
Scott Chalabi comes back to save the day
I wanna lick his are you bro okay Wow
oh yeah oh yeah somebody awesome scenes
in this movie that I keep forgetting
about I said movie wow that shows that
should say a lot actually
Scott Shalaby
he doesn't [ __ ] with Scott shall be no
you know oh hello someone's getting laid
tonight there he is
what's up my man I shot
thank you please come in mr. Shelby
would you care for a coffee oh no thanks
do you play a little I tried once but I
think the owner the course is still
looking for now it's an interesting
sport it requires strength but also a
cool head and absolute precision what
you can't hit a few balls with me
there's no danger of damaging the Greens
here alright okay take off your jacket
grab a club let's do it
I've started my ass it's no reason
started my ass alright give me the club
give me to get me to go give it give it
I'll show you the balls are in that
basket yeah I can see them
geez alright
let's show how it's done the most
important thing is to grip the club
Quran huh
when you feel ready you swing alright
that's totally not how you grip but hey
let's do it anyway
uh-huh uh-huh Hey Oh
Hondo can pray together huh impressive
you seem to have a knack phone I'm an a
cur
no beginner's luck
now I'm assuming you didn't invite me
here just to play golf mr. Kramer oh you
got invited I hear you've been asking
questions about my son that's right I
want to know if Gordy is linked to the
origami killer case in any way oh so
he's dead please bad thing ah all right
let's do this again up and kabocha ba
hell yeah I beat you all that my son had
nothing to do with that sorted case well
then he has nothing to fear from my
investigation
you have no business investigating my
son I told you he had nothing to do with
it with all due respect mr. Kramer it's
up to me to decide who I want to
investigate don't don't [ __ ] around
Scott Shelby I know you're Scotch lb and
all of it I'm an influential man mr.
Shaw here comes the threat appear very
well
are you trying to buy me
yes let's just say I'm trying to show
you where your interest lies how much do
you want to leave my son alone
you can't buy nice enemy I think you
misunderstood me I don't play that game
at FATCA tell me don't don't near my son
mr. show if you do you'll regret it
have a nice day mr. Kramer Oh
hell yeah it's got Chalabi well he's
gonna drive hard now
so to get barrel
don't you [ __ ] it all right Ethan
Mars
Ethan Mars yeah alright let's do it for
us this is my favorite mmm smells
delicious from the kitchen I think I'll
be some good Italian food today bread
ooh
yeah this is star sir what what that is
this
ah no this is not well this is pretty
cool too actually
porcelain lizards they look new out of
place with the rest of this old beat-up
stuff huh break it
haha alright nothing there what about
this one hey kid check it
oh here we go aha blah and we found a
key
oh yeah what you gonna do what you gonna
do when we find out keep all right let's
go inside
there should be an origami marking or
some [ __ ] like yeah it is ah I don't
like this brush you're not gonna like
this brush let the third trial begin
okay let's do this
are you prepared to suffer to save your
son you have five minutes to cut off the
last section of one of your fingers in
front of the camera if you succeed you
will get your reward I don't know Alya I
gotta do it I have no choice gotta find
a short object somebody'll make a clean
cut I don't want to have to start
hacking away at it oh [ __ ] me
no alright then what else do we need
Shawn I have no choice I have to go
through with it I have no choice for
Shawn right what about the pains gonna
be intense gotta find some way to reduce
it well what do we got in here there's a
toilet uh what about the lock Shawn
Shawn [ __ ] Mars or Ethan is your name
I should eat that you better shape up
cuz you need a cut off your finger
no bad Ethan daddy daddy going back in
it
alright alright disinfectant got a
disinfect the wound if I want to have a
chance of surviving open the [ __ ]
cabinet well [ __ ] you what do we got in
here with you I'll shut it aside Oh like
that alright
I don't ever wear k disinfectant pills
where you're not seem like you're in a
rush here Ethan
don't refuse doing this only a finger ah
[ __ ] it let's just do it then
all right oh okay okay okay I had I had
put it down I had to put it down to pick
up something new I get it now I can't
open these all right
that doesn't make sense but [ __ ] it I'll
take it
put it down
all right we need to find something else
shut up
what was that there's something in the
sink
no we're not taking that one put it down
that's disgusting I don't want to use
the sister what's that an axe
all right I think an axe is actually
better all right
I add I probably use an axe okay huh
okay oh you're just on the floor [ __ ]
hell no
no don't put it down gentle
deep breath you can do this do it for
your son Ethan do it for your son - it
for yours come on it's not hard to
breathe
alright do it do it do it do it ah don't
[ __ ] out on me then don't [ __ ] out on
me now ah ah
Lady Gaga oh [ __ ] stop [ __ ] out stop
pissing out we don't have time for that
alright
come on and kick it like a [ __ ]
I all right ha ha buzzsaw all right
don't fail oh don't fan out sorry
yeah
Oh
haha
under the desk
I see Silesia wasn't relying i crawl
along you cut off your finger pitch
all right we got them all we got them
all gray we [ __ ] poor Ethan
yeah it's totally Roosevelt Street for
sure all right let's get out of here
Ethan ah this game is [ __ ] insane
insane I tell ya for Ethan then poor son
of a [ __ ] god damnit this game is
[ __ ] epic I think it's a lot better
than walking dead but that is my opinion
anyway I can figure the finger subscribe
get on the road today and I'll see you
next episode of I have on it everybody
you